[Musique]
regin à vire sérieuses et décoratrice et
architectes elle conçoit des intérieurs
de rêve pour les plus beaux hôtels sont
luxe à elle habitait un petit village de
touraine d'où elle se déplace dans le
monde entier
mais le couronna virus est arrivé et
tout a changé
am que de ça à notre chalet rabbinat
blessure locateur immédiate
moi j'ai l'habitude quand même de voir
toutes les teams avec qui je travaille
sur mon projet spécifique tous les cinq
semaines pour poser toutes les questions
qu'il faut résoudre parce que ce qui est
fait sur une journée ça prend une
semaine
en échange de mails en décalage horaire
et c'est donc et aussi quand on se voit
on
rien qu ensemble on amène à nous montre
toujours de nouvelles choses sont courts
et puis à pour ouvrir un peu la tête
donc c'est non ça manque
regin a ne prend plus l'avion un
handicap de taille pour suivre un
chantier à distance elle a dû re
localiser et fait désormais appel à un
menuisier du village pour certaines
réalisations
9 il ya quoi il ya il ya 4 mm défense
oui mais je peux te proposer celui là on
humilie m je pense qu'on peut produire
un lézard ou les moquettes le tapis ou
des accessoires
c'est aussi une aventure qu'on fait avec
l'autre cette aventure accueillons
distance maëlle a pas lieu comme des
millions de personnes à travers le monde
le télétravail a bouleversé la vie de
regin a
[Musique]
voulue ou subie handicapant ou au
contraire enrichissant il s'impose à la
campagne dans les villes que l'on soit à
son compte ou salarié employé au pdg
il révolutionne nos habitudes je pense
qu'il ya encore des relations humaines à
avoir dans le travail mais ça fait
partie de l'avenue qu'il ya certaines
tâches qui peuvent mieux effectuer à la
maison qu'au bureau mais une entreprise
qui qui fait que les gens se voient
jamais n'existe pas en fait
télétravail à son tour sont ses pattes
nabeul c'est une révolution c'est clair
bienvenue chez pentalog signe des temps
comme vous pouvez le voir le parking
évident d'habitude il est rempli de
voiture venez avec moi je vous fait
visiter le siège social qui accueille
d'ordinaire près d'une quarantaine de
personnes en reçoit seulement
quelques-unes dans cette entreprise du
loiret qui conçoit et vend du service
numérique
seuls 5 à 10% des 1200 salariés à
travers le monde sont revenus au bureau
donc ici le bureau du patron qui est
lui-même en télétravail depuis le début
du confinement dans ce bureau
d'habitude il ya environ 10 personnes
donc on a réduit à trois personnes
comme pour toutes les entreprises du
digital le passage au télétravail a été
plutôt facile
tous les bureaux que l'on a visité
ensuite sont vides ici ici on a un autre
ici on en a un autre derrière toutes les
personnes soient en télétravail depuis
depuis le confinement et on a choisi de
continuer le télétravail justement dans
la période qui est encore incertaine
est ce que tout le monde va bien ça va
bien chaque jour l'entreprise organise
des cafés virtuel où les salariés
peuvent échanger sur d'autres sujets que
le travail
c'est pas forcément quelque chose que
l'on souhaite en permanence mais en tout
cas c'est tout à fait faisable avec les
outils d'aujourd'hui on peut on peut
pallier le manque de contact
en réel avec avec les compagnies et la
vidéo
si le télétravail est largement facilité
dans les entreprises du digital ou
l'ordinateur est l'outil essentiel
il n'en est pas de même partout comme
l'expliquent benoît sert spécialiste des
ressources humaines ça veut dire grandes
entreprises vous devrez faire cohabiter
deux types de population des gens qui
ont accès au télétravail pour partie et
donc bah ça améliore leur qualité de vie
au travail soit parce qu'ils ne s'y
rendent pas donc ils n'ont pas les
contraintes des transports soyons de
liberté d'organisation et en plus ils
ont nécessairement un management plus
dans la confiance que contraignant où
vous contrôlez et de l'autre dans la
même entreprise d'étals gens qui ne
bénéficient pas de ça parce qu'ils ont
des métiers qui fait que c'est
impossible et en télétravail
vous avez un risque d'inéquité de
traitement entre les salariés et sa
l'inéquité d'abord elle est interdite
par la loi
mais surtout le sentiment d'inéquité
c'est le sentiment le plus dévastateur
dans une organisation
c'est ce que les médecins du travail
appelle l'injustice à organisationnel
injustice entre ceux qui télétravaillent
et les autres
ce n'est pas l'avis du patronat kaehlin
et quittez la vous avez une possibilité
c'est la liberté du travail quelque part
la liberté du travail
si vous avez possibilité de le faire
chez vous et si on vous autorise à le
faire chez vous tant mieux après en
revanche vous avez assez ap d'usiné
heures de tourneur fraiseur pas vous
demain on va pas vous livrer un tour un
tour dans votre sous-sol pour huissier
travail et d'en faire à venir à vie bon
on va re d alors c'est ça le problème
c'est la redéfinition des enjeux des
tâches et des coûts à une trentaine de
kilomètres de son bureau à pentalog
ludovic ne quitte plus sa maison pour
aller à son travail une économie de
temps de trajet d'une heure par jour
mais pas seulement avec le co vide c'est
un peu changé la donne on est passé
d'une journée par semaine à 100% du
temps moi je vois que des côtés positifs
eux
enfin sur par rapport à la vie familiale
puisque du coup les enfants ou ma femme
je vois beaucoup plus qu'avant ouais ça
aurait fait quoi je passe plus de temps
avec eux donc c'est appréciable et même
après pour des activités que peuvent
faire il ya des quantités de 18h moi je
pourrai jamais les emmener faire une
activité maintenance et des choses que
je peux faire
d'un point de vue familial allait jouer
un petit peu parce que je travaille
d'accord je pense qu'il ya encore des
relations humaines à avoir dans le
travail mais ça fait partie de l'avenir
parce que certaines personnes peuvent
choisir aussi de vivre autre part pour
pour convenance personnelle mais de
malgré tout avoir un travail qui les
intéressent ou le siège est à un autre
endroit moins de salariés en présentiel
et c'est l'aménagement des surfaces
qu'il faut repenser entièrement à paris
dès ce qu'est au premier aménageur
français de bureaux est devenu un acteur
majeur de la praye confinement vous
faites des quartiers on va dire il ya
une équipe qui va se retrouver un
certain endroit et au sein de cette
équipe ont créé une flexibilité
personnes 200 postes de travail pour
commencer et ils peuvent remonter ils
peuvent monter jusqu'à 250 parce qu'on
va faire des aménagements spécifiques à
choisir des mobiliers avec eux qui leur
permettent de grossir
quand son ombre pour coller au mieux aux
attentes des skis haut à multiplier les
sondages 73% des personnes aimeraient
télétravail et au moins deux jours par
semaine
79% des sondés sont même prêts à
sacrifier leurs bureaux attitrés pour
plus de télétravail 43% regrette quand
même le monde d'émulation collective
il ya un marché un nouveau marché qui se
développe de conception de mobilier et
des solutions pour le télétravail pour
la maison et des questions au sein des
entreprises
comment est ce que je peux aider les
collaborateurs est ce que je le prend en
charge en tant qu'entreprise même pour
les collaborateurs ou pas et comment
aussi comment est ce que je peux encadré
tout cela pour que en fait on le
collaborateur il peut travailler de
manière productive et avec une sécurité
à la maison
toutes les entreprises ne prennent pas
en charge les frais de leurs salariés à
distance comme le constate ce
responsable de la cfdt
on s'aperçoit qu'on a des gens qui par
exemple télétravail avec leur matériel
personnel qui supportent finalement tous
les frais que supporter auparavant
l'entreprise dont qui il ya quand même
des règles qui font un peu pour
quadriller un petit peu cette cette
activité là il faut aussi que la
définition des tâches soient soit
repréciser on ne télétravail pas comme
quand on faisait du présentiel
c'est à dire qu il faut plus réfléchir
sur effectivement non plus de la
présence mais de la mission si vous avez
demain une majorité de gens qui
travaillent en télétravail
il va falloir se poser la question de
l'opportunité de calcul et en heure
parce qu'évidemment pour quelqu'un en
forfait jours c'est beaucoup
l'encadrement c'est facile vous avez un
certain nombre de jours par an 200 8 210
220 peu importe
et ça vous êtes en télétravail une
partie de ces jours là je note
d'ailleurs quand dans les accords qui
viennent d'être signés en a au moins
deux très célèbre qui sont mgen d'un
côté et psa de l'autre il calcule un
jour ils disent c'est un nombre de jours
de travail par an est-ce qu'on
s'achemine vers une évolution pourtant
d'un mode de travail historique la
calcul du travail historique en disant
en fait on va plutôt cac et le nombre de
jours travaillés dans l'année plutôt que
le nombre d'heures travaillées par
semaine je sais pas mais en tout cas ce
serait une révolution sociale de premier
niveau
nous sommes chez blg une générale
orléans et le parking est plein presque
tous les salariés ont retrouvé le chemin
du bureau et expérimentent le flex
office différents lieux sont conçues
pour s'adapter à toutes les tâches
cabine téléphone espace silence ou de
réunions ici
le télétravail est plutôt un handicap
ici donc je dois voir un branchement à
ce niveau en fin de journée je trouve
quand on est en télétravail sa fatigue
beaucoup plus parce que l'attention
était beaucoup plus importante et la
fatigue
même si on est chez soi on est très bien
on est on va dire dans les petits shows
seront mais l'attention que l'on doit
apporter pour f1 pour convaincre aussi
parce qu'il ya les expressions qui sont
tout autres il n'ya plus le regard c'est
à travers un écran et ce petit notion de
pour trouver la solution c'est plus
compliqué le retour en présentiel c'est
plus d'efficacité pour cette entreprise
qui conçoit et livre des centres
commerciaux et des plateformes
logistiques
mais c'est aussi pour son pdg une
certaine façon de concevoir les rapports
humains
je pense que là on a beaucoup de deux
occasions de s'isoler beaucoup beaucoup
trop ça aussi c'est un peu de banalités
le télétravail peut en être une de plus
ce mélange fin de compte de la vie
professionnelle de la vie privée je vois
bien que c'est c'est quelque chose qui
me correspond pas du tout à ce que nous
avons connu nous mais qui fait partie
aujourd'hui de la vie la vraie richesse
ce sont les hommes
une idée dépassée certains experts
affirment que les générations futures
préférons interagir avec les machines
dans ce monde là un patron français
pourrait avoir sa secrétaire en moldavie
et ses ingénieurs en inde ou au brésil
que restera-t-il alors du sentiment
d'appartenance qui crée la culture
entreprise si ce n'est les personnes que
l'on crée du culte en entreprise ça se
décrète pas qu'on y parle culture c'est
ça c'est la manière des gens travaillant
sans la manne anti son manager la
manière ils se retrouvent ils se
retrouvent pas l'ambiance à
bienveillance de tout ce que vous voulez
donc si les gens ne se voit jamais et a
plus d'entreprise en cap une culture
d'entreprise
c'est pour ça que tout télétravail n'est
pas une option
on vit pas dans un monde idéal tout se
passe pas très bien dans les entreprises
il ya des entreprises où ça se passe
bien et tant mieux mais il ya aussi des
entreprises ça se passe pas spécialement
bien où les gens sont contraints
aujourd'hui de faire du télétravail
comment on arrive à des conciliation des
temps des salariés entre l'activité
professionnelle et la vie personnelle et
c'est une formidable occasion et on sawi
le télétravail peut être une révolution
si la crise actuelle continue
d'accélérer la digitalisation le
télétravail a de beaux jours devant lui
tout l'enjeu des négociations actuelles
sera de trouver un difficile équilibre
entre les intérêts des uns et ceux des
autres
[Musique]